let me ask you mentioned a disagreement
with weinberg on reality
uh could you elaborate a little bit
well i
obviously i don't disagree with steve
weinberg on physics itself i wouldn't
know enough to even begin to do that
and clearly you know he's one of the
founders of the standard model and so on
and it works
to a level of accuracy that no physical
theory has ever worked at before
i suppose the question in my mind is
something that
in one way could go back to the
philosopher immanuel kunt in the 18th
century namely
can we really ever
convince ourselves
that we have
come to grips
with something that is
not in itself
knowable
to us
by our senses
or even except in the most remote way
through the complex instruments that we
make as to what it is that underlies
everything can we corral it
with mathematics and experimental
structures yes
uh do i think that a particular way of
corralling nature will inevitably play
itself out
i don't know
it always has
i'll put it to you that way
um
so the basic question is
can we
comprehend reality sounds like a very
trippy question because a lot of it
rests on definitions of uh no and
comprehend and reality but
get to the bottom of it
like it's it's turtles on top of turtles
can we get to the bottom turtle
well i say hello maybe i can
put it to you this way
in
a way that i we often
i often begin discussions in a class on
uh the history of
science and so on
and say i'm looking at you
yes
um you are in fact a figment of my
imagination
you have a messed up imagination yes
well what do i mean by that
if i were a dragonfly
looking at you
whatever my
nervous system would form
by way of
a perceptual structure
would is clearly be utterly different
from what
my brain
and perceptual system altogether is
forming
when i look at you
who's right
is it me or the dragonfly
well the dragonfly is certainly very
impressive so i don't know but yes it's
uh the observer matters
well how does what is that supposed to
tell us about objective reality well i
think it means that
it's very difficult to get beyond
the constructs
that our perceptual system
is leading us to when we make apparatus
and devices and so on we're still making
things uh the results of which are the
outputs of which we process perceptually
in various ways
and and an analogy i like to use with
the students sometimes is this all right
they all have their laptops open in
front of them of course okay
and um i've sent them
something to read
and i say okay click on it and open it
up so pdf opens up i said what are you
looking at
i said say well i'm looking at you know
the paper that you sent me
i said no you're not
what you're looking at is a stream of
light coming off leds or lcds coming off
a screen
and and i said what happens when you use
your mouse and move that
fake piece of paper on the screen around
what are you doing you're not moving a
piece of paper around are you you're
moving a construct around
a construct that's being processed so
that our perceptual system can interact
with it in the way we interact with
pieces of paper yes but it's not
real
you